(funky electronic music)
- We use a lot of IV
therapy to treat hangovers.
If we use the right vitamins,
there won't be any side effects.
Success rate using IV therapy
is over 75% in our practice.
- I can't really remember the last time
I've been super hungover.
- I really do hope that IV
therapy works, and works well.
- Maybe I'll go through this and go,
wow, this is life changing.
- If this works, it's
kind of scary in a way
because now there's like no
consequences for drinking.
No consequences for drinking.
No consequences.
- All right, guys, great.
- Bottoms up.
That's pretty smooth.
All right, let's do another.
- Oh, oh (beep)!
- We could just start with two.
Let's just kick it off.
Better to get it over with right away.
- Oh yeah!
- That one wasn't as good.
- I'm up to here on the
sass meter for you, okay.
- Okay, I'm sorry.
- Oh, Jesus Christ.
- We're taking a nosedive
here very quickly.
- Let's just go.
- Just go as in take another shot?
- No, I...
- Come on, guys, let's go.
Just wait till we meet up with Maycie.
- She was supposed to meet up wth us;
I don't know where she is right now.
- [Maycie] Just finished beer number one.
- My beautiful, beautiful boys.
- Is it Ms Jake's shot?
- Well, you could stop him.
- I'm not gonna.
(laughter)
- Hi, what a do, welcome to Real Mature.
- [Voiceover] We got a limo!
Limo, limo, limo.
- [Voiceover] Hollywood, what's up?
Nobody? All right.
- Get this party started.
(laughter)
- Right now we're getting
pulled over by the cops.
- [Voiceover] Oh my God, we actually are.
- Best friends forever.
- [Voiceover] We're finally at the bar.
- Maycie, you scoundrel!
This is mine.
- Yes!
- Yay!
(laughter)
- [Ryan] We've mixed so many alcohols.
- Yeah, we sure have.
- Mixed so many sweet drinks.
We are so (beep) tomorrow.
- I seriously just want to die.
- Oh God.
- [Voiceover] Look, these
cocks just killed this bird.
- I don't care; I wish they would kill me.
- I'm actually really afraid of needles,
but I just wanna feel better.
So just stick it in me, doc.
- So who wants to go first?
- [Voiceover] Ryan I think, yeah.
- All right.
- All right, let's get it over with.
- His butthole's making that same face.
I can't watch it happen.
- Mm.
- [Doctor] Not too bad, right?
- I'm a little bit nervous.
When I woke up this
morning I felt like dying.
- Ah!
- [Voiceover] Jen, it's okay.
- Careful, don't bend.
- Sorry.
- It's all good, girl.
- (beep) Wednesdays, am I right?
Or is it Tuesday?
- [Voiceover] It's Wednesday, Ryan.
- I'll put that there.
- Thank you.
- In it goes.
- You didn't even flinch.
- I'm excited, 'cause I don't feel good
and I want this to work,
like as fast as possible.
It's in!
Ooh, I can taste the vitamin already.
- I'm having a great time with you guys.
- Bring our bag over to brunch?
- When was the last time
any of you were that drunk?
- Last weekend.
- How, where, where
does all this liquid go?
Are we filling up like balloons right now?
- I'm going to take an IV bag selfie.
Everybody turn around.
- Excuse me.
I have places to be.
- See you suckers at the water cooler.
- Oh, Jesus!
- All right, I'm stepping
away from this situation.
- Mm, I'm almost done.
- There's a bump right there, look out.
There's a bump, there's a bump.
- I'm gonna lift it.
- What?!
- Don't act like you haven't
seen weirder things, Ned.
You of all people.
- No, but this is pretty weird.
- I think our IVs got twisted.
- I'd totally twist IV
bags with you any day.
- This is gonna be us in 60 years, Ryan,
except it'll be like, you know...
- Or this could just be
the way of the future.
- Oh my God!
- Oh Jesus. What have you done?
Jen, your blood!
Your precious blood.
- Oh, holy (beep).
- What did you do, Jen?
All that for a banana?
I think the most concerning thing
is that my big takeaway
from this was like,
drinking on a Tuesday?
Ah, it wasn't that bad.
- Can we as humanity handle this?
- I do feel like I'm
starting to feel better,
but I don't know if it's just in my head.
- We're done.
- Woo!
- I didn't think it would
work as well as it did.
- I still feel pretty hungover right now.
- I think it certainly worked.
It's just that I'm not sure if
it would be worth it for me.
Other people, Ryan, maybe.
It might be worth it for
Ryan to do this all the time.
- I was on my deathbed this morning,
and I 100% feel better right now.
- But, me, nah. I'm good.
- Shall we FaceTime my dad?
- Why would we FaceTime your dad, ever?
- I don't know. He's nice,
my dad's really nice.
- Hey, Ryan, Ryan, Ryan.
- I'm gonna listen to--
- Guys, we're all at the party (mumbles).